well I'm now joined by is spokesman uh
Elon Levy Alon Levy Alon Levy thank you
very much indeed for joining me um you
heard my monologue there I've said from
the start of this conflict that I felt a
real moral quandry not about uh October
the 7th I'm crystal clear about the
horror that happened there I'm
completely clear that Israel not only
had a duty to its people to defend
itself after that but had a
responsibility to do it um the question
is always been in my mind what is a
proportionate response and as we have
this pause at the moment thank God for
the release of many of the hostages it's
also time for everybody to pause and ask
some pertinent questions of Israel about
what the real plan is here going forward
so let me start just by asking
you where does this go now uh we've got
a two two-day extension to this pause
more hostages will come out but it won't
be all of them in fact Hamas don't even
know where many of the hostages are
they're with other uh Islamic
fundamentalist groups within Gaza uh
Netanyahu has already said your prime
minister that he wants to pick up the
attacks as soon as this pause is
finished but to what end and how far
will you
go Israel's campaign now in response to
the October 7th Massacre is
proportionate to the threat that we face
and that threat is a second October 7th
third October 7th the fourth million
October
exactly as Hamas is promising to do to
murder every man woman child in our
country we really wish we were not in
this situation pi and for many years
Israel has been putting off a possible
campaign to topple Hamas but the October
7th Massacre left us no choice it was
the deadliest Massacre of Jews since the
Holocaust it was the deadliest terror
attack in world history since 911 and in
response to that our c campaign is going
to continue to destroy Hamas this war
will end with the end of Hamas because
we cannot allow it to remain in power
and we know that the scenes on our
screens are very difficult and we're
doing everything we can to minimize
civilian casualties but everyone in
Israel understands that the consequences
of inaction would be too great to Bear
because we cannot leave Hamas in power
and our hostages in Gaza we cannot leave
Hamas emboldened to continue attacking
our people to launch another murderous
campaign like it did on October 7th with
those barbaric acts that you have spoken
so powerfully against the burnings the
beheadings the abducting we the
abductions we simply cannot go back to 6
a.m. on October 7th that will not happen
that Massacre was the straw that broke
the back of a very strong camel and this
war is going to end with the end of
Hamas okay how many uh Palestinians
including Hamas terrorists have you so
far killed we know that we've killed
thousands of terrorists we know hang
okay let let me ask you about that so
the the Hamas run health authority says
it's over 14,000 people have now been
killed of that I mean do you a do you
accept those numbers because they have
been endorsed by other bodies but do you
accept that those numbers are fairly
accurate historically they have
been Hamas is the organization the army
of Terror that on October 7th burned
beheaded abducted people and then lied
about it to the entire media so it is
the opposite of a credible source and
understand but you but you accept given
that previous figures that they have
given during the many years of his
conflict about casualties have turned
out to be pretty accurate do you accept
this is likely to be the range of people
who've been killed first of all they
haven't been proven accurate because
historically Hamas never admits in the
course of a war that its own terrorists
are killed and that only comes to light
afterwards I'll say what we know about
the numbers and we don't don't have
exact numbers because Pierce I can't
tell you how many Israelis were murdered
in the October 7th Massacre because we
still have dozens of body parts dozens
of body bags of unidentifiable human
remains the idea that I can give you an
exact number is not realistic but here's
what I can tell you one we know we've
killed thousands of terrorists because
our campaign has been targeting to
Target the monsters who perpetrated the
October 7 how do you know they're
terrorist two we know how do we know how
do you tell a Hamas terrorist from a
Palestinian civilian who's not part of
Hamas Hamas is making it very difficult
to do that because we know that it's how
do you know you've killed
thousands because we know who we are
targeting we are targeting on the basis
of precise intelligence this isn't an
indiscriminate bombardment as many would
like to paint it Hamas knows that we do
not Target civilians it seems to know
that better than some in the west that's
why for example we recently Declassified
a an intercepted phone call of Islamic
Jihad terrorists talking about
transporting an anti-tank missile in a
baby pram because they know perfectly
well that Israel is trying to my not the
civilians okay but here's my problem
with this is that by your own admission
you don't know how many Hamas terrorists
and I I categorize people who belong to
the Hamas organization as terrorists
just for you know for clarity but you
don't actually know do you how many of
them you've killed and I by your own by
your own by own admission uh just a few
moments ago he said they make it
incredibly difficult for you to work out
who is a Hamas terrorist and who is a
civilian that seems to me part of the
problem that you have with the Optics of
this to The Wider world is that they're
seeing horrible imagery all day long I
mean it's it's just the worst thing I've
ever seen all over social media the
worst thing we've ever seen were the
atrocities at
Hamas yeah I've not seen thankfully I've
not seen what many journalist scene
which is the 45 minute film of that and
I understand it's absolutely horrific
and I'm not making I'm not making any
comparison I would not say anything is
worse than that so for the record uh but
the horrible imagery all day long it is
suggesting to people that there are
thousands and thousands of thousands of
women and a lot of children maybe as
many as five six thousand children now
have been killed by these uh uh air
strikes and now the ground attack and I
think the problem that you have and I
say this respectfully the problem you
have
is that you don't actually know how many
Hamas terrorists you're killing and if
you're honest you don't do
you appears the sad fact is everyone who
has been killed in the Gaza Strip in the
last month and a half would still be
alive if Hamas had not launched this war
with the October 7th Massacre and then
fought out of densely populated civilian
areas that it has done its dandas to
prevent people from evacuating in order
to get to safety while we tried to get
them to safety but I want to say
something about the civilian casualties
because I think this is important we
know that we've killed thousands of
terrorists we know that Hamas is
inflating the numbers you don't actually
know that we believe but that's that's
my problem with this you say you say you
have but when I push you for the details
you don't have them and that that for me
that's the problem exactly how many
Israelis were murdered in the October
7th
because I agree with you that is utterly
horrific that you still can't determine
how many people were killed that day
because of the horrors that were
perpetrated you and I in complete
agreement but nor do you know how many
of these Hamas terrorists you're killing
it could be that vast numbers of them
and we think there are around 35,000
perhaps in total that vast numbers of
them either disappeared into the tunnels
and have been safely there ever since or
simply went South with the million or
more Palestinian supposed civilians that
went down there maybe a lot of them
infiltrated that that group and a dam
the South you don't actually know do you
for sure he during the Afghanistan war
and I believe your brother a real
military hero fought in that War British
military spokes people could not have
given you a running commentary in real
time about exactly how many Taliban
fighters were killed during the second
world war and I know your grandfather
was a war hero who fought the Japanese
to liberate Burma the British army could
not have given a running tally of how
many civilians were killed there or how
many Japanese were being killed these
are facts that become clear when the fog
of War clears and what I can tell you is
that when the fog of War clears and the
numbers become clearer about the
civilian combatant ratio inside the Gaza
Strip and you compare that to other
counterterrorism wars fought by Western
armies like the British and Afghanistan
like the British in Iraq like the
British against Islamic State that ratio
is going to prove very firmly the extent
to which the Israeli Army has gone to
try to keep civilians on the other side
safe from the consequences of their own
DEC their own leaders Reckless and evil
and barbaric attempts to try to keep
them In Harm's Way appears every every
civilian casualty is a tragedy civilian
casualties are a feature of every war
and they are a feature of this war that
Hamas began and that Hamas is foring
true but the reason I'm pushing you the
reason I'm pushing you on it is simply
because you say you've killed thousands
of hassed terrorists and the reason I
think this is such a an important
question is there have been reports that
once this pause is over that Israel
intends to then attack him a South uh
and may give further warnings to people
that out of certain areas but will
attack him South and presumably destroy
uh the areas that you attack there as
you have done in the north making it
almost uninhabitable for people to
return to uh and all of this is part of
operation get rid of Hamas but if the
world doesn't know how much of Hamas
you're getting rid of but only sees day
after day hour after hour images of
children dead women dead innocent
civilians caught up in this then I think
the global support for Israel is going
to dissipate very quickly that's why
it's really important I think for Israel
to better demonstrate to people that
your mission is being accomplished
because you know otherwise you could be
here in six months a year and the
civilian death toll in in Gaza could be
over a 100,000 and we might be having
the same conversation where you're still
not sure how many Hamas terrorists
you've killed that's the problem it
seems to me appears I'm slightly
surprised by this question because in
the fog of war no country no military in
the history of warfare could ever give
you an exact running tally I'm Nota the
casualties but I'm saying we know that
we are targeting Hamas we know that we
are targeting the monsters who
perpetrated the October 7th Massacre and
we know that we are trying to foil their
strategy to hide behind women and
children and just this week we've
exposed the world the evidence of the
bunkers that they built underneath the
shifa hospital that so many have spent
so long trying to cover up and deny that
Hamas is using that strategy let me ask
you what happens the assuming this war
ends and please God it ends sooner
rather than later but assuming it ends
Benjamin Netanyahu has said he intends
to effectively occupy Israel to occupy
Gaza for security reasons indefinitely
what really what he said indefinitely
you you would be in charge of security I
mean you're already in charge of a lot
of their food their energy their water
if you start adding security as an
umbrella basically you're occupying Gaza
that is not anything that anybody wants
out side of it seems to me him and his
cabinet I mean it's not what you would
it's not what you would want is it no
Pier Israel does not want to occupy the
Gaza Strip and that is why 18 years ago
Israel left the Gaza Strip so why would
he say why would he say he wants to do
that indefinitely for security reasons
because the sad fact is the prime
minister has said we do not want to
occupy Gaza to say that the Prime
Minister said that is simply false he
said Israel will have to for some period
to exercise security control to prevent
that area being demilitarized just as
President Biden said in his own column
in the Washington Post that there will
have to be Arrangements how do you do
that we're going to have to prevent
smuggling of any weapons inside the Gaza
Strip after we have totally destroyed
the Hamas Terror infrastructure you know
p in the years that Israel has been out
of the Gaza Strip all that concrete that
went into Gaza and was supposed to build
people's houses went into the went into
tunnels all those pipes that were
supposed to go into water pipes Hamas
dug them out and then filmed propaganda
videos of them turning those water pipes
them at Israel and that is what we have
to prevent to stop this happening again
but if you displace the vast majority of
civilians as you have and you destroy
large amounts of their homes what do
they come back
to after the day after Hamas and I wish
it were next week but it will take time
there are three things that are going to
have to happen the first is the Gaza
Strip must be demilitarized we will
never allow it to be used as a base for
operations from a terrorist group to
direct attacks against our people just
as the UK and 85 other nations came
together to deny Isis its territorial
stronghold and they did to R to ra to
raaka and muscle what they did to raaka
and muscle because they understood that
a Jihadi group like that must never be
allowed to hold territory to attack
innocent people the second thing is the
Gaza Strip must be deradicalized you
know the youngest terrorists who
perpetrated the October 7th Massacre
weren't even born when Israel vacated
the Gaza Strip into 2005 and they were
raised on a diet to glorify
J and the third thing I want to address
the question of reconstruction the Gaza
Strip is going to have to be rebuilt and
this time it's going to have to be
rebuilt in a way that ensures that the
concrete genuinely goes to people's
homes and doesn't go into into the
tunnels because otherwise we're going to
be in the same
situation and the consequences for
the but with respect the only way you
can do all this is with a form of
occupation whether you want to call it
that or not that's the only way you can
do this and my other question to you
would be this is that is there not a
danger you talk about radicalization
there is there not a danger that the
longer this goes on and the more
innocent people you kill as you try and
Target uh Hamas that you build up a
whole new generation of Palestinians who
are radicalized to hate Israel and want
of exact Revenge isn't that a real a
real concern right now you know I don't
think during the second world war when
the Allies were bombing the Germans and
the Japanese people claim that if you
continue bombing Germans and Japanese
you'll raise a new generation of Nazis
and that's because they realized these
were people who were radicalized beyond
measure and after the war there had to
be a serious process of deradicalization
appears the facts are that 85% of
Palestinians across the West Bank and
the Gaza Strip support hamas's
atrocities on October 7th that is the
first polling evidence that has come out
the level of radicalization is already
severe and it is that radical element
that we have to deny a stronghold from
which to perpetrate a roties against our
people and we think it's important that
the whole International Community
understand the extent of the rot of the
Hamas death cult that has raised a whole
generation tragically after the greatest
opportunity for peace in the Middle East
that 2005 withdrawal there has to be a
serious push towards deradicalization to
ensure that this never happen again and
we expect the international work hand in
hand with us on that okay listen I've
got to leave it there but the big
question is whether what you're doing
now what you intend to do in the next
few weeks and months will actually begin
the end of that radicalization or make
it a lot worse and that is a question I
think we just don't know the answer to
uh but Alon thank you very much indeed
for joining me could I complete it an
answer perhaps if you're
quick if this war doesn't end with the
end of Hamas and the return of our
hostages we know that Hamas will attack
us again that's what it says it wants to
do and so if you're talking to me about
extremism we know that a Hamas that
feels emboldened because the world tells
said Israel has no right to defend
itself that is the Surefire recipe for
more radicalism and extremism and more
death and we're determined to put an end
to this cycle of violence and we'll end
it we'll end this war and we'll do it by
ending Hamas heon Levy I really
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much indeed thank you very much Pi
anytime